We've talked about the scam grifting around
the virus, and we previously mentioned the
super rich televangelists scammer Kenneth
Copeland Copelands, 83 years old.
He's built a net worth of 760 million dollars,
if you can believe it, on the backs of scamming
poor Christians out of money.
Now, poor might be economically poor or cognitively
poor or I don't know.
You know, you can interpret that however however
you want, but it has afforded Kenneth Copeland
private jets and houses and cars and the whole
thing for this guy.
We have a new clip of him finishing Corona
virus by commanding God to destroy it.
So we're going to look at the clip.
If you're listening today on the radio or
to the audio podcast, I encourage you to go
and find the YouTube clip for this story,
because the visual is really important.
You're going to see Copeland behaving like
a lunatic, but he also has another guy next
to him.
It's almost like a hype man at a lectern next
to him, sort of repeating some of the things
Copeland says, egging on the insanity.
It's really, really crazy.
And remember, for Kenneth Copeland to do this
stuff, you've got to keep tithing.
You have to keep sending him 10 percent of
your income.
Take a look at this name.
Thank you, Jesus.
Oarfish of the Prophet of God execute judgment
on you.
So.
I tried to judge what you destroy or you kill
her.
You get out.
You break.
Don't you get off this nation, man.
Vaccination.
Yes.
It actually makes me physically uncomfortable
to watch this stuff.
It's not like a cringe reaction.
It's almost like a G.I. distress.
Like I start to get noxious watching this
stuff.
And of course, all of the normal contradictions,
Satan brought the virus.
So he commands God to destroy it.
Why didn't God merely prevent the virus in
the first place?
He's asking for a vaccine.
Well, who makes the vaccine?
Is it God?
Why would God allow the virus and then make
a vaccine?
Why not just prevent the virus to begin with?
Seems simpler to me.
Oh, David, come on.
God works in mysterious ways, and you've got
to keep sending Kenneth Copeland money.
Let's watch a little bit more of this if we
can tolerate it.
I call you Don.
Calm down, calm down from your forehead and
you calm down.
And you got to put your head in the garden
of what really gets me about this is that
in this context where this guy has like a
congregation, I guess you'd call it, or maybe
it's a ministry.
I don't know.
In this context, this guy's wearing a suit
and there's cameras in the room and he says,
send me money for these rants.
There is no practical difference in terms
of what this guy is saying between Kenneth
Copeland wearing a suit in front of cameras
and, you know, a guy ranting in the subway
who should be committed to a psych ward.
And I'm not saying that pejoratively about
the guy in the subway.
We're talking about mental illness here.
Right.
The difference is one guy's wearing a suit.
The other guy's not.
One guy has cameras filming him.
The other one does not.
One guy has marketing behind him saying you
should be sending in money for this stuff.
The other guy does not.
That's the only material difference here.
Now, some people would disagree with me and
would say, David, Kenneth Copeland's not crazy.
He's just evil.
He knows that this stuff is lies.
He's doing it not because he believes it.
And he's crazy.
He's doing it just to steal people's money.
I don't disagree.
The point is, the rhetoric is the type of
stuff that paranoid schizophrenics in psych
wards would normally say.
He may well be acting just to get people's
money, no doubt about it.
But the only real difference is the marketing,
the PR and Kenneth Copeland has better lighting
than the guy ranting on the street corner.
If these faith healers really had the powers
go to a hospital and heal someone seriously
ill from cobia 19.
Right.
Go and put your hands and say your prayers
for someone on a ventilator and heal them.
It would be immoral not to if this non-sense
actually worked.
Then we'd have something to talk about.
Really sad that old folks keep getting scammed.
They keep going out there getting haircuts.
They're hanging out at malls.
They're ignoring social distancing rules.
And part of it is they can send this guy cash
to pray away the virus.
Part of it is, you know, watching Fox News
and the rhetoric there.
It's very, very ugly stuff.
And it's not a joke.
It's not a joke.
People are actually dying as a
result
of this.